tenemos aquí una molécula de cloro
eterno y bueno no le tenemos que llamar
1 cloro el 11 porque ésta es la única
configuración posible de estos átomos ok
no importa cómo queramos acomodar los
siempre vamos a terminar con esta
acomodación entonces el nombre
sistemático iupac es cloro eterno pero
en muchísimos lados comúnmente se le
llama cloruro de vinilo dibujé aquí
también un cloruro de hidrógeno con
todos sus electrones de valencia y
dibujé de morado el electrón de valencia
proporcionado por el hidrógeno el chiste
es que tenemos un montón de estos cloro
eternos en una mezcla de cloruro de
hidrógeno ya hemos hecho esto un montón
de veces ahora lo que queremos saber es
qué pasa con estas moléculas que
reacciones pueden suceder también
sabemos que este cloro es mucho más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno por lo
que esta molécula tiene unas cargas
parciales del lado del cloro
tiene una carga parcial negativa y del
lado del hidrógeno tiene una carga
parcial positiva y otra vez como ya
hemos visto antes
este hidrógeno que siente que no está
pasando suficiente tiempo con su
electrón quiere obtener un electrón para
él solito y alguno de estos dos carbonos
que se encuentran en este doble enlace
podrían regalarle uno de sus electrones
ahora cuál de estos dos carbonos va a
ser el que pierda su electrón pues
entonces tenemos que ver cuál de estos
dos carbonos tiene más vecinos con más
electrones a ver este carbono está
enlazado con estos dos hidrógenos y pues
cada uno de estos hidrógenos tiene
únicamente un electrón entonces no
podrían prestarle nada a este carbono
sin embargo este otro carbono está
enlazado con este átomo de cloro que
tiene un montón de electrones y si este
carbono se convirtiera en un cárabo
catión perdiendo uno de sus electrones
este cloro fácilmente podría prestarle
de vez en cuando sus electrones
haciendo que éste sea un kart vocación
mucho más estable entonces este carbono
va a perder uno de sus electrones
digamos que es éste el electrón que va a
perder el cual se lo va a quedar este
hidrógeno y en ese mismo segundo
este electrón que antes era del
hidrógeno se lo va a quedar el cloro
ahora como este electrón sigue siendo de
este carbono entonces se va a formar un
enlace entre este carbono y este
hidrógeno
tenemos por aquí un carbono con sus dos
hidrógenos y ahora en lugar de tener un
enlace doble tenemos un enlace simple
con otro carbono que está enlazado con
un cloro y con otro hidrógeno pero este
carbono perdió uno de sus electrones que
fue a dar a este hidrógeno formando un
enlace entre este carbono y ese
hidrógeno entonces ahora este carbono
tiene nada más tres electrones de
valencia
así es que tiene una carga positiva se
ha convertido en un cárabo catión y este
cloro por aquí tiene los electrones de
valencia que tenía antes
con este electrón y además tiene el
electrón de valencia que antes
pertenecía al hidrógeno
este electrón de valencia entonces este
cloro ahora tiene un electrón de más se
ha convertido en una unión de cloruro y
tiene una carga negativa
si seguimos el patrón que vimos en los
últimos vídeos podríamos pensar que lo
más lógico sería que ahorita este cloro
y éste carbó catión se sintieran
atraídos y este cloro le pasar a uno de
sus electrones al carbono y formaran un
enlace y es bastante probable que eso
pase sin embargo eso no es lo único que
puede ocurrir hay otra cosa que ocurre
con aún mayor probabilidad
resulta que estamos sumergidos en una
mezcla que tiene muchísimos muchísimos
muchísimos cloro eternos entonces pues
vamos a dibujar otro cloro eterno por
aquí un carbono doble enlace con otro
carbono que tiene un cloro un hidrógeno
y este de aquí tiene otros dos
hidrógenos aunque ahí tenemos muchísimas
moléculas de éstas ahora a éste carbó
catión le gustaría recuperar un electrón
y si definitivamente puede tomarlo de
este cloro pero hay muchísimas de estas
moléculas y este enlace doble hace que
estos carbonos puedan prestar mucho más
fácilmente sus electrones ok y este
carbono que se encuentra enlazado con
este cloro si llegara a perder uno de
sus electrones y se volvieran un kart
vocaciòn este cloro podría compartir sus
electrones haciendo a este un kart
vocación mucho más estable por lo que no
sería tan difícil que este carbono le
regalara uno de sus electrones
en la cee
a este otro kart vocación a diferencia
del cloro que es muy electro negativo y
que no quiere perder ni uno solo de sus
electrones entonces vamos a ver cómo se
ven ahora las moléculas aunque
pensándolo bien debería de copiar esto
que vamos a colocar por aquí entonces
este electrón fue a dar a éste carbó
catión por lo que ahora tiene 1 2 3 4
electrones de valencia así es que ya no
tiene una carga positiva pero este
electrón sigue perteneciendo a este
carbono que ahora va a ser el carbono
azul vamos a dibujarlo por aquí y
entonces se forma un enlace entre estos
dos carbonos ahora este carbono tiene
dos hidrógenos dos hidrógenos y ahora
tiene un enlace simple con este otro
carbono enlace simple con carbono rojo y
este carbono tiene un hidrógeno y un
cloro hidrógeno
cloro ahora este carbono en este proceso
perdió un electrón ahora solo tiene 123
electrones de valencia entonces tiene
una carga positiva y ahora es un kart
bocatín así es que está buscando quien
le puede regalar un electrón entonces
que se imaginen qué va a pasar ahora
pues por un lado éste anión cloruro
podría sentirse atraído por éste carbó
catión y regalarle uno de sus electrones
sin embargo recuerda que todavía estamos
inmersos en un mar de cloro eterno así
es que por ahí hay otro cloro eterno que
estoy dibujando en estos momentos
al igual que como vimos en el paso
anterior es muy probable que este
carbono que está enlazado con este cloro
le de uno de sus electrones a éste carbó
catión y este carbono que ahora va a ser
el carbono morado se queda con sube
electrón y se forma un enlace entre
estos dos carbonos vamos a dibujarlo
para eso vamos a pegar y necesitamos más
espacio ok entonces tenemos este carbono
morado que como este carbono le regaló
uno de sus electrones a este otro
carbono y ahora están formando un enlace
este carbono ya tiene sus cuatro
electrones de valencia por lo cual ya no
es un kart vocación y ya no tiene carga
positiva y este carbono pues tiene dos
hidrógenos dos hidrógenos ahora tiene un
enlace simple con este de aquí que ahora
es un kart vocaciòn este carbono que
ahora es un kart vocación con carga
positiva porque perdió uno de sus
electrones
que este carbono ya no fuera del carbó
catión o sea se están pasando la bolita
de quién es el carb ocasión pero bueno
este kart vocación está enlazado con un
hidrógeno y con un cloro
entonces te puedes imaginar que sigue a
continuación cierto o sea seguimos
agregándole y agregándole y agregándole
cloruro de vinilo y esta cadena se hace
cada vez más grande hasta que en algún
momento nos acabamos los cloruros de
vinilo o entra este cloro en acción y
hace que se acabe la cadena pero bueno
si continuará así la cadena tenemos que
pensar en una forma más concisa de
describir a esta cadena así es que pues
vamos a poner por aquí a ver aquí
tenemos ch3 voy a ponerlo como h3c
después está enlazado con este carbono
que a su vez está enlazado con este
hidrógeno que vamos a poner de una vez y
con este claro que vamos a poner por acá
ahora este carbono a su vez está
enlazado con este carbono pero resulta
que aquí es donde empieza el patrón que
se repite entonces a ver todo este
pedazo es el patrón que se repite una y
otra y otra vez cada que agregamos un
cloruro de vinilo entonces lo vamos a
poner de azul
ok tenemos un carbono con dos hidrógenos
ch2 que está enlazado con este carbono
que tiene un hidrógeno y un cloro
el cloro aunque ahora como es el patrón
que se repite vamos a poner aquí unos
paréntesis y aquí podríamos poner la
cantidad de veces que se repite si no
sabemos exactamente cuántas veces se
repite pero sabemos que son muchísimas
generalmente ponemos por aquí una n
ahora si sabemos el número exacto de
veces que se repite este pedazo de la
cadena por ejemplo si sabemos que se
repite mil veces entonces ponemos por
aquí
milk pero esto podría repetirse millones
de millones de millones de veces podría
ser una cadena super larga y lo que
estamos describiendo en este vídeo es un
polímero con el que seguro te has
encontrado de hecho te prometo que hay
un montón de él en tu propia casa pero
bueno eventualmente nos vamos a acabar
todos los cloruros de vinilo y vamos a
llegar al final de la cadena tenemos
aquí
se h 2c h 2 y este carbono que ahorita
lo tenemos como un kart vocación una vez
que ya nos acabamos todos los cloruros
de vinilo entonces ahora si a éste a
nyon de cloro no le va a quedar de otra
más que regalarle uno de sus electrones
y entonces se va a formar un enlace
entre este carbono y el cloro que tiene
aquí el resto de sus electrones
y bueno este carbono también estaba
enlazado con este otro cloro por aquí y
listo así es el final de la cadena
aunque ya empezamos con un ch3 ch cloro
después tenemos este pedazo de cadena
que se repite
se repite muchísimas muchísimas
muchísimas veces tanto como indique este
número de aquí y después tenemos se h 2c
h cloro y cloro y como tenemos
muchísimos carbonos porque este pedazo
se repite muchísimas veces entonces
estamos hablando de un polímero
poli
me polímero y el nombre de esta molécula
pues bueno estos pedazos vinieron del
cloruro cloruro de vinilo de vinilo y
hay muchísimos de ellos por lo que
agregamos el prefijo poli y si sacamos
las iniciales obtenemos psb pero si las
cambiáramos del lugar a como estarían si
estuviéramos hablando inglés entonces
obtenemos las letras
de cee y seguramente has escuchado de
las piezas de plomería de pvc son estos
tubos de plástico que hay en muchos
lugares y de esto es de lo que están
hechos de policloruro de vinilo